a bad friend is like a shadow
on a sunny day
run
you won't run away
on a cloudy day
look for it
you won't find
it i can calculate the motion of
heavenly bodies
but not the madness of people
nature is pleased with simplicity
and nature is no dummy
what we know
is a drop
what we don't know
is an ocean
tact is the knack of making a point
without making an enemy
gravity explains the motions of the
planets
but it cannot explain who sets the
planets in motion
truth is ever to be found in the
simplicity
and not in the multiplicity and
confusion of things
no great discovery was ever made without
a bold guess
a man may imagine things that are false
but he can only understand things that
are true
if i have ever made any valuable
discoveries
it has been due more to patient
attention
than to any other talent
what goes up
must come down
and to every action there is always an
equal and opposite or contrary reaction
he who thinks half-heartedly
will not believe in god
but he who really thinks has to believe
in god
live your life as an exclamation
rather than an explanation
you have to make the rules
not follow them
to myself
i am only a child playing on the beach
while vast oceans of truth lie
undiscovered before me
to explain all nature
is too difficult a task for any one man
or even for any one age
plato is my friend
aristotle is my friend
but my greatest friend
is truth
one thing secures us whatever be tied
the scriptures assure us that the lord
will provide
in the absence of any other proof the
thumb alone would convince me of god's
existence
truth is the offspring of silence and
meditation
there are more sure marks of
authenticity in the bible than in any
profane history
if others would think as hard as i did
than they would
as a blind man has no idea of colors
so have we no idea of the manner by
which
the all-wise god perceives and
understands all things
if i have done great things
it's because i was standing in the
closet of smart men taking notes
and then publishing their ideas as my
own
they who search after the philosopher's
stone
are by their own rules
obliged to a strict and religious life
the less money a person has
the more his heart is
the more time and devotion one spends in
the worship of false gods
the less he is able to spend in that
of the true one
the best and free medicine
is hunger
philosophy is such an importantly
litigious lady
bad a man as good as to be engaged in
lawsuits
as have to do with her
yeah sex is cool
but have you tried solving the
brachistochrone problem in a single
night
you